a triumphant moment for Syrian president
Bashar al-assad he ended 12 years of
diplomatic isolation and delivered a
speech calling for Arab Unity and an end
to what he called foreign interference
above all we must leave domestic affairs
to our respective people all we need to
do is prevent foreign forces from
intervening we hold this Summit in an
unstable Global landscape but Syria
remains in the heart of the Arab region
which is crowned by this Summit which I
hope will pave the way for a New Journey
of joint Arab action Harmony peace and
prosperity rather than destruction and
War
2011 thousands of civilians took to the
streets of Syria calling for reforms
assets ties deteriorated with golf
leaders when his troops opened fire on
civilians destroyed entire Villages and
used chemical weapons the Arab League
suspended Syria's membership in response
the U.N believes nearly 400 000 people
were killed in Syria
Saudi Arabia led a growing number of
Arab Nations seeking to reconcile with
Assad
the kingdom and the United Arab Emirates
have pushed for the reconciliation
arguing it's the only way to end the
violence and allow millions of people to
return to their homes
we can't allow our lands to be a
platform for conflicts enough with the
conflicts that have crippled development
in our region it's with pleasure today
that Dr Bashar al-assad the president of
Syria is present here as the league of
Arab states has handed down a resolution
allowing Syria to resume involvement in
our meetings and we hope that this will
contribute to the restoration of peace
and Security in Syria in order to lift
up and resume its role in the Arab
region for a better future for the
entire region widely seen as inefficient
the Arab League has grappled for decades
with divisions and competing agendas
among its 22 member states divide that
deepened after the 2011 Arab Spring the
organization established in 1945 to
increase Regional cooperation is now
widely accused of failing to deliver on
its promises
it's done little to end the violence in
Syria Yemen Libya or Sudan Saudi Arabia
is trying to broker a peace deal between
Sudan's warring factions
there is a approachment between the two
sides but it's premature at this stage
to talk about a breakthrough but despite
the Saudi push for a united front to
tackle security and economic challenges
the Arab League appears more divided
than ever
tens of thousands of people have been